[Música]
segundo bloque económico de la mañana en
directo américa jorge hurtado nuevamente
en el estudio jorge hablamos de la
crisis del suministro en materias primas
que continúa golpeando el comercio
mundial bueno y uno de los sectores que
más está haciendo afectados el sector
automotriz debido a no solo la escasez
de suministros sino también porque
enfrentan la escasez de chips o
semiconductores y de eso vamos a hablar
los bloqueos en las cadenas de
suministro ya generan desabastecimiento
en varios países del mundo y
afectaciones en la producción de grandes
industrias también existe el temor raúl
porque las ventas de la navidad' sean
afectadas por este retraso en la llegada
de los productos el fabricante toyota
anunció este viernes que va a reducir su
producción de vehículos en noviembre en
15% debido a la escasez mundial de chips
y los recortes de energía que también
afectan a china la producción de la
compañía en japón será recortada en 50
mil unidades mientras que la producción
internacional se recortará a otras 100
mil unidades la empresa dijo que la
escasez de semiconductores es uno de los
factores principales para este nuevo
recorte ahora jorge explícanos un poco
qué son estos chips y por qué son tan
importantes para la producción productos
bueno cuando hablamos de un chip dos
semiconductores aquel material que puede
actuar tanto como un medio para permitir
el paso de una corriente eléctrica o
como aislante de la misma se estima que
un vehículo moderno como el que usamos
todos los días contiene en promedio mil
400 de estos chips o semiconductores que
sirven para cosas esenciales raúl como
cuando pones la radio cuando subís la
ventana cuando prendes las luces o usas
el aire acondicionado la crisis de estos
chips se inicia con la pandemia cuando
las fábricas de vehículos cerraron y los
fabricantes de chips cambiaron sus
líneas de producción pero ahora que las
fábricas reabrieron los fabricantes han
dicho que no pueden suplir la demanda
vamos a ver qué va a pasar entonces con
este déficit de estos son microchips
jorgé pero vamos a hablar ahora al
bitcoin porque existe la posibilidad de
que pueda cotizar en aguadilla jorge y
los bitcoin están muy emocionados con
esta noticia y a la espera de que la
comisión de bolsa y valores de eeuu
autorice el primer fondo cotizado de té
efe de futuro de bitcoin de suceder
sería un paso histórico para las cripto
maneras el bitcoin que es la cripto
manera más grande del mundo subió un 4.5
por ciento a su nivel más alto de mayo y
ronda los 59 mil 290 dólares casi 60 mil
dólares y se espera que los productos
comiencen a operar la próxima semana
según fuentes de bloomberg la comisión
de bolsa ha dicho antes que el script o
moneda son riesgosa para los inversores
raúl te cuento únete efe es un fondo de
inversión cuya principal característica
es que se negocia en mercados de valores
secundarios puede verse interpretarse
como un equipo de fútbol conformado por
varios jugadores y estos jugadores
serían como bonos acciones materias
primas que buscan mejorar sus
rendimientos y pueden convertirse en
efectivo rápidamente también se vende al
igual que lo haría con una acción normal
solamente teniendo un bic o en ya yo
creo que seríamos felices lo mejor es
que vamos a hablar ahora de dos meses de
la toma de los talibanes del poder en
afganistán le pregunto cómo está la
economía bueno los organismos
internacionales hablan de que afganistán
está al borde del colapso sanitario y
financiero tras el recorte de la ayuda
internacional los fondos de la comunidad
internacional representan alrededor del
43 por ciento del producto interno bruto
anual allí según los datos del banco
mundial pero la llegada de los talibanes
desencadenó
en el cierre de bancos la pérdida de
empleos y un golpe la actividad
comercial el portavoz de unicef en
afganistán ha dicho que pese a que la
comunidad internacional se comprometió a
aportar más de mil millones de dólares
sólo han recibido un pequeño porcentaje
de esos fondos raúl en afganistán hay 18
millones de personas que necesitan
asistencia humanitaria para sobrevivir
también hay 3.5 millones de desplazados
por la guerra y la sequía y sólo este
año hubo 700 mil desplazados el grupo
g20 junto en edades a entidades como el
fondo monetario internacional y el banco
mundial están discutiendo y analizando
cómo brindar ayuda humanitaria si los
talibanes como intermediarios de este
dinero y se espera que el producto
interno bruto en afganistán disminuye un
13,2 por ciento el próximo año nada
alentador lo que le espera a afganistán
en materia de economía y cifras pero
ahora jorge le pregunto cómo abrió world
with cómo están los indicadores bueno
vamos con eso wall street abrió en verde
este viernes después de que goldman
sachs completó una fuerte temporada de
ganancias para los grandes bancos en
europa las bolsas operan al alza por el
optimismo de que la subida
será temporal y en asia los mercados
cerraron la semana al alza después de
que las fuertes ganancias corporativas
impulsaron las acciones americanas para
finalizar que nuestra como cifra el día
90 millones de dólares de afganistán en
energía la compañía eléctrica estatal de
afganistán pidió a naciones unidas ayuda
para saldar las facturas pendientes en
electricidad que tienen con proveedores
de asia central pues jorge gracias por
toda la información económica el día de
hoy viernes 15 de octubre finales de
semana ya se va a poder ir a descansar
nos vemos el lunes con más economía
nosotros vamos directos a parís
[Música]